My husband was on his way out to get a cookies
and cream soft serve,
but I told him I'll just make it for him instead,
so that's exactly what I did.
I started by making my Oreos by combining some flour,
cocoa powder, butter,
some sugar and egg
and then letting that go until it all comes together.
Then I grabbed a baking sheet
that was lined with Parchment paper
and formed little balls that I spaced evenly onto it.
I ended up making two baking sheets
and once the balls were formed
I used my palm to flatten them out.
I put them in the fridge for about 10 minutes
and then pop them in the oven for 10 minutes
and while those cooled
I got started on my filling,
which was just butter,
vanilla, and some powdered sugar.
I beat that until it was light and fluffy
and then transferred it over to a little ziploc bag
cause I didn't have a piping bag.
The filling was so delicious
I kept snacking on it while I was filling my Oreos.
After spreading an even layer on one of the cookies,
I put another one on top
and there you go!
I put some of them aside and then use the rest
for my soft serve ice cream.
I did a mix of cookies without filling and with filling.
For my ice cream
I combine some milk,
heavy cream,
some sugar, some salt
and vanilla.
Put that in My Kitchen Aid.
And let that churn
until it reached the consistency I wanted.
Then I put all of my Oreo cookies in there,
let it go for another five to 10 minutes,
and then it had the perfect soft serve consistency.
Spooned it into my little ramekin,
topped it with some more Oreo cookies,
and I could not resist having a bowl myself.
And it was really good.